oh I told you we have been together for
13 years we want to try to go on a date
with with other people without getting
in trouble so John and I both we decided
to do a casting call Andre to grams
whoever one is 20 date with joins who
I'm joining it with me no Monty they had
to agree to these things it wasn't like
I could just reach out and just grab
baby boy yeah and they had to be like
for sure attracted to us you know a lot
of people might think that this is
really really weird because it really is
like why we're doing this but I think
it's really fun I mean we've been
together for a long time we just wanted
to know what dating was like today she's
gonna pick her date for me and I'm gonna
pick the guy we do love each other a lot
but this is really fun this is supposed
to be a fun experiment not like oh my
god we leave each other after right Yeah
right
definitely I'm going to pick Chrissie
for John because super super adventurous
you scuba dive she's always outdoors
she's very fierce and she has that extra
sauce that could bring to John's life oh
my god let your hand go how are you
[Music]
gonna give me the Tomb Raider I'm going
to choose some lip for Tim because he
seems like he is very very passionate
poetic and seems like the face is
fashion very seriously and he can also
dance and he has a killer bod which I do
not have you look great today thank you
thank you
love your huh oh thank you ah that's
cute thank you that's cute I like your
alright yeah
oh thank you it's a little uh Chilean
okay so uh you know is what it is
yeah so what do you like to do before
high school what I'm you school down
yeah like oh my I'm already intrigued we
got a warrior princess oh okay what made
you like respond to my casting like
looking for a date
well of course you're cute second I
really just watching you and just seem
like I enjoy your personality you're
really bubbly thought I'd give it a try
so have you ever like dated an Asian
forever yeah well you are my first Asian
like date like ever are you only into a
dress no no of course not I think it's
really more just about like connection
and just you know how you vie about the
person why are you on a date if you have
yeah so you always get these like in
these little funny conversations like
you know these little debates about oh
you know how would it be dating somebody
else and cuz I've never been with
another woman really no was your first
girlfriend first girlfriend first
everything only she's had working won't
but like I mean as far as like anything
else beyond it
yeah yeah I've been
my god it might be in the market for a
sidechick in New York or oh what's the
favorite thing to do like you I love her
target reaction range
really yeah I love her tour you know
what I'm drink for dough are you serious
yeah yeah I'm from Tampa really wait
wait here from Orlando yeah oh my god
that's like two hours away
how long have you been in LA I've been
in LA for about five years now I came
out here to pursue the arts acting I'm
actually a photographer by trade as well
oh wow yeah more in common that's right
you don't mind me asking why you what
can she post a photo of you yeah it's
not I gotta go meet you really you think
I mean I mean I try no why are you using
ball is your son we have a great smile
even bigger stuff well thank you kind of
like a full package I'm single by choice
I want to focus on my career and going
at this time and out I just want to
really propel myself so that way like
not only for my future but for whoever
is featured on the works
so what happens if she ends up with a
guy that she goes from the data with now
you're getting scared ain't no man will
get scared man
he ain't gonna be better than me man I
got tenure I got tenure
I have asked have you ever stolen a man
out of a relationship
it was not like purposely he had a
girlfriend at the time with you and he
managers became best friends like we
just played like emotionally I don't
pass judgment you know when you came out
of this date where you kind of like
hoping that you would look for something
else that's different from John I liked
obviously besides being patient you know
I think Don is the perfect boyfriend our
biggest problem is that we fight because
he's too much I need someone to be able
to say no when it's time to say no you
know like I'm a pushover to like I'm
super super nice but he's nice to the
point where like the whole world would
take away under him you know we were
raised like you know so we're immigrants
Noreen and we were talking like - you
know like - good right your refuge
easier we were taught like how to like
gamble and like win and negotiate so
many people take advantage of him and
then we just kalaiy like that's our
biggest problem and then we just argue
and argue and argue because it's just so
hard to date someone and be with someone
for 15 years and have everyone in his
life like take advantage of him I have
to ask you the question what is the
question why are you going a lot Mary oh
my god I knew that was coming thirty
years proposing it's not a matter of why
am I not it's a matter of why I have it
I'm like probably the master
procrastinator it's never gonna be a
right time and I know that you know but
every time it seems like it's the right
time something falls in front of it it's
just like oh my god I gotta pay this
bill I gotta do this I gotta do that and
in this like in every time we have these
conversations and we have debates all
the time like you know she's a she's a
very humble girl
she's a very simple woman she always
says I want $100 great it doesn't matter
he doesn't matter doesn't matter this is
like but I want to give you the world
every time I was like oh okay I saved up
enough money and then something happens
and then I just got to spend all that
money again and then I have to like kind
of recuperate and that's just what
happened over and over and over again
but then I start to realize that do to
start seeing is either do it now she's
gonna leave my parents who wants me to
marry John and it's like what stuffs
also you know but what's stopping us I
see missing out on it what his dream
girl is or am I missing link out on an
Asian guy right so that your parents
want you to marry an Asian guy like from
there you're young it was really hard
for my parents to accept John but they
accepted after like four years and now
they like to love love love them like
more than me like they really do I lost
him this was nothing short of
spectacular I had an amazing time I had
I'm so it like like it's crazy it was
nice meeting you all right thank you did
definitely different from me thank you
for being here Amanda thank you thank
you here's Ben hunger - you're not one
of those rien huggers that like dislikes
have - oh and I can feel your muscles
when you hug me so that's really good
yeah really nice body I had a really
great time like I mean the things that
we talked about I mean we didn't really
get all youthere you with it you know we
kind of just scratched the surface about
you know just you know family just
covering the basics then y'all talked
about something that was a little bit
more passionate like I mean that's that
and that literally goes to show our
personality how we connect with other
people you know and it's always gonna be
like that you know you can have a
connection with this guy I can have a
connection with this girl but you know
at the same time as good that we
experience and say these type of things
actually
appreciate me more
that's exactly what this experiment was
born so we can learn things about not
only ourselves but about other people in
the experience and other people in the
way they do relationships we can
incorporate that into our own
relationship so we were to fight would
you hair up and be like hey I might be
in the market was that [ __ ] you know you
know know what my ass